[Music]
we are going to get vulcan up and
running from scratch because why not
so
that's pretty much the plan
is to start playing around with shaders
i'm gonna do an empty project in visual
studio 2019 first thing we want to do is
get a
main goal start adding in
[Music]
[Music]
start out by designing these functions
and we'll do them in a
just to keep the main nice and clean
now we need to run it
probably just want to use one of these
samples
shaders again
[Music]
fine
[Music]
it's not seeing it
you shouldn't have to do this
as if we have to
it still says see it though
i think we're gonna do our shaders in a
different way entirely we're just gonna
load the binaries
i don't need like any of this stuff
[Music]
it's written somewhere
[Music]
oh we're gonna fail to read on our
shader inspected
considering we haven't set all that up
[Music]
but it should be pretty he's gonna do is
run v
these two shaders
[Music]
quickbridge should go to the output
directory shouldn't it their interfaces
code is on github
which is still down
but uh
should
[Music]
pollution platform config
[Music]
okay let's see if that works
other code here i think i got this
written so
i think i have it in the cmg
[Music]
binary code
and we probably need
so rarely use try catch
hooray
are we done
[Music]
all right now we can start playing
around with the shaders because that's
what we're here to do yeah we'll try to
get the crater next time
or one of these and just kind of get any
of them from shader toy
or any sort of cool example working
that means we can move forward
the even more stuff just to make our own
and what next game engine
all right i'll see you guys later have a
good day or evening
[Music]
till next time peace
[Music]
[Music]
you